i'm at boston right now i gave a speech
last night at boston university on this
topic the topic was teach the abcs not
the lgbts
and the topic made people crazy there
were there were more shenanigans at this
speech i gave last night than i've seen
at a campus speech in years
first of all the event was sold out
and then the captain of the bu police
department wouldn't let half the
audience into the room
the captain of the bu police department
i don't know what his ax was to grind he
wouldn't let our photographer into the
rooms there actually aren't any even
professional photos from the event so
you had half of the room was stuck
outside and they had to stream the the
speech on their
phone and then of the people who were
let in there was a a planned walkout by
the left-wing lunatic kids i had an
inkling of who those kids were going to
be because they were all the only people
in the room with the masks this
does underscore my point my favorite
part about the airplane mask mandate
being lifted which is just that you can
now tell with 100 certainty exactly who
the libs are so you just know you're
like okay i guess i'm sitting next to
one lib and one normal person and that's
okay that's why i just i'm just gonna
plan out my conversation now i'm gonna
plan out my flight so i'm looking and i
see rows of these these students wearing
the masks and i think okay they're going
to stage some some protest
and right when i got to the topic of the
gender unicorn the gender unicorn is
this weird assignment about a purple
sexually confused unicorn that is being
handed out to third graders and second
graders and kindergartners and even is
being used in certain pre-k classrooms
the gender unicorn and the gender-bred
man that's another
weird creepy
sexually confused cookie assignment
these are being used with really young
kids when i mention that the the kids
stormed up and flipped me off and yelled
and screamed and said all crazy things
and waved the transgender flag and then
walked out of the room this issue
makes
people crazy and the the point i i drove
home last night at bu you can watch my
speech online
it's it's been streamed to youtube it's
over at the yaf youtube channel the
point i made here is that
it's not enough just to stop the weird
sex lessons in the classroom
you've got to go further teachers need
to teach something it's not enough just
to say hey don't talk about
transgenderism to six-year-olds
well what are we going to talk about
it's
if you're reading a story in a
kindergarten classroom and the story is
about a family of bears
mama bear daddy bear and and baby bear
i don't think anyone would object to
that right even though the lesson does
have implicit lessons about sex about
family about human nature where did baby
bear come from baby bear came from mama
bear and daddy bear and mama bear and
daddy bear live together in a marriage
because that's
a sort of ordinary normal thing to do
well what if the the story instead being
read to this kindergarten classroom
we're about daddy bear and daddy bear's
boyfriend and daddy bear's boyfriend's
polyamorous trans billy goat and and
this were being read to five-year-olds
would we object to that i think we
probably would we would you say don't no
thank you don't read that to my kid
both stories make implicit claims and
have implicit lessons about sex and
family and human nature but we like the
normal one and we don't like the one
with the trans billy goat
it's not just as some republicans are
saying it's not just that this education
law in florida
bans all sexual discourse entirely
sometimes you'll hear republicans say
you could you could call it the don't
say straight bill because it doesn't
discriminate between gay or straight or
trans or this it it just says all sexual
conduct is out but i just don't think
that's really what we're talking about
here i don't think that really gets to
the heart of the issue you can't teach
anything even even all the way down to
an elementary school classroom you can't
teach anything about
history literature biology certainly
civics you can't teach these things if
you don't
touch on topics involving
men and women and human nature that
those those things are just too
central sex and desire and family and
community those things are too central
to the human condition to avoid and so i
think we've got to stand up and say no
we have norms not saying we got to be
mean to gay guys not saying we need to
be cruel to people who are confused
about their sex but
we're allowed to have norms there's
nothing bigoted about that the reason
that republicans don't want to say any
of these things is because we're afraid
of being called a homophobe or a
transphobe or a phobephobe or whatever
nonsense slur the libs want to throw at
us but who cares they're going to throw
slurs at you anyway and what we're
standing up for is perfectly ordinary
and normal and everybody would have
agreed with it five years ago but now
you go to a college campus and people
lose their minds talking about a really
basic fact of human nature the craziest
protests i've ever had the only time i
was physically assaulted on a campus was
talking about this issue
this issue where the overton window as
it's sometimes called or the standards
have just completely changed to the
point that now you're not allowed to say
men and women are different
if you for instance
if you go on to twitter
and you don't make the general claim
that men and women are different but you
go in
you're you're retweeting bruce jenner
bruce jenner says i'm a woman and i want
to use the women's bathroom
let's say he's actually one of the least
offenders on this transgender ideology
but
let's go with it he's one of the most
prominent ones
and he says i want to use the women's
bathroom and you retweet that and you
say you are not a woman bruce jenner
that's a violation of twitter's
terms of conduct you you could lose your
twitter account for that
because the overton window has shifted
but if you retweeted some i don't know
straight white mail and said you are a
terrible person and you are an oppressor
and you're the cause of all the evil in
the world you won't lose your twitter
account
the latter is objectively more offensive
than the former the latter is not true
while the former is true and yet you'll
be you'll be banned for saying the true
thing and you'll be fine for saying
the false thing which is why it's so
important that we get a hold on twitter
and facebook and google and the big tech
platforms that control our speech and
therefore control our democracy i'm so
glad you liked that clip if you want
more clips head on over and subscribe
ring that bell you'll get many more
clips go subscribe to the michael
knowles show too we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]